welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Barbie
the 2023 movie starring Margot Robbie as
the Mattel icon in a meta existential
Beach Musical that pays so much to
Stanley Kubrick The Matrix The Wizard of
Oz and of course the history of Mattel
that my Barbie fanatic wife Kelly has
been catching me up on since one of our
first dates was the visit to Epcot who I
guess recreate the 1994 Barbie's
birthday party VHS that she loved as a
kid and has made me watch all of it's
Barbie's World and yes I'm thinking
about dying so yeah I'm gonna break down
this movie but please know sag-aftra has
informed us that entertainment
journalists like new rock stars are
allowed to cover movies and TV during
the strike I don't care what
misinformation other people working for
the amptp have told you to spread this
information we are entertainment
journalists and we're allowed to cover
this news we support sag and the wga and
their strikes that these artists get
what they deserve and really our goal
and our coverage is to celebrate the
Artistry and how it cannot be replaced
by AI to be clear we won't be doing any
future agreements with the studios to
promote their releases the way
influencers sometimes do not until the
strike is resolved or we get further
guidance okay cool awesome let's go the
film opens with a near shot for shot
homage to Stanley Kubrick's 2001 A Space
Odyssey the famous dawn of
dawn of sequence set to the
Sergio since the beginning of time since
the first little girl ever existed there
have been dolls
director and co-writer Greta gurig's
attention to detail is incredible
instead of a dry skull there's a
discarded shoe instead of Apes picking
fleas out of each other's hair that's
girls brushing non-existent air on the
doll's heads the narrator of this movie
is Helen Mirren whose Majestic voice
also narrates every episode of
documentary now on IFC all the girls are
dressed in drab clothes waiting for a
fashion icon from the heavens and yeah
there is truth to this opening because
before Barbie arrived in 1959 dolls
really were just dolls Barbie really did
represent a profound paradigm shift and
we talk about the old dolls hellamir and
says the girls who played with him could
only have a player being mothers which
can be fun at least for a while anyway
ask your mother a hint of the
mother-daughter themes at the end of
this movie that Barbie's Creator Ruth
Handler named the doll after her
daughter Barbara the whole thing is
really a mother-daughter story and we're
gonna get to some mind-blowing truth at
the end of this video this mean girl
with blonde hair and glasses seems to be
a young granted gerwick herself at least
based on this 2002 high school photo
where she played Dorothy in The Wizard
of Oz by the way the Wizard of Oz comes
back throughout this film and in my
ongoing theory that every American movie
is trying to be either Citizen Kane or
The Wizard of Oz Barbie is 100 Wizard of
Oz this point of view shot of the giant
Barbie shadowed by the Sun the Crescent
Moon behind her is exactly like Stanley
Kubrick's shot of the monolith in 2001
the monolith being the mysterious symbol
of technological advancement and its
destructive power an important concept
to Christopher Nolan and his films
especially Interstellar with the Taurus
robot that I argued in my deep dive is a
key to it all and it's very ironic that
this movie and Nolan's Oppenheimer about
similar stuff are coming out the same
weekend because they're two great films
tackling similar Cooper Concepts just in
different ways but Oppenheimer is
citizen game I'll get to that in my
breakdown of Oppenheimer and I need more
time to break down that movie because I
saw it after this one now listen closely
as this little girl touches Barbie's leg
yeah it sounds like they mixed in the
hum of a lightsaber from Star Wars there
this black and white striped swimsuit is
the very first outfit Barbie wore when
she was first released by Mattel in
1959. now many of these details I'm
talking about were first pointed out by
Jessica Clemens who broke down the final
trailer with me in her earlier
breakdowns she did an amazing job with
her research Jess moved on to the ringer
a few months ago and I hope she comes
back to visit so many Barbie bits and
Austin recently and I'd love to talk
talking Barbie with her I miss you Jess
now just like Kubrick's eighth is
inspired to use the bone as a weapon
baby Greta lists her old doll to smash
her tea party in the same exact slow
motion imagery and then flings it all in
the air as it flips and match cuts to
the Barbie title in 2001 it matched cut
to a satellite showing Mankind's leap
into technology here it's the Barbie
logo which Jessica pointed out is the
font of the 1975-1991 era of the logo
Helen Mirren talks us through the
history of Barbie in her various forms
we see a doctor a lawyer astronaut
Fitness expert dozens and dozens of
different careers all of these actually
specific versions of Barbie that were
seen over the decades and we fly down
onto Barbie land a heart-shaped realm on
the coast where the surrounding terrain
is drab and Sandy inside the border the
water is suddenly a brighter shade of
blue clearly plastic according to this
overhead map Barbie's cul-de-sac is the
dot of the eye in Barbie land our Barbie
stereotypical Barbie lives in her Barbie
Dream House inspired by mid-century
modernist architecture found in Palm
Springs including the Kaufman desert
house by Richard Nutra and everything
like in lizzo's song that we hear over
this is pink specifically the shade of
panda tone 219 and they use so much of
that shade while building these sets
that it resulted in an international
shortage of it and thank you to better
help for sponsoring this video here at
new rockstars we like to figure out what
makes movies work go frame by frame to
figure out what's really going on but
when we need Insight on what's really
going on with ourselves we use Better
Health betterhelp is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 30 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started just
answer a few questions about what you're
looking for from therapy and what your
preferences are better help will then
match you with a therapist from their
Network that's right for you after that
talk to your therapist however you feel
comfortable whether it's via text chat
phone or video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
more scheduling flexibility and at a
more affordable price get 10 percent off
your first month at betterhelp.com new
rockstars that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy as Barbie begins her day I love
how lizzo's lyrics are commenting on her
in real time even cramming in some words
to fit in the Rhythm hey Barbie I like
your style even if that were really a
mirror you'd see a perfect smile later
lizzo spells out the word pink P pretty
I intelligent and never sad K cool and I
love that she doesn't say k Ken because
Barbie doesn't need Ken so she'd just
rather misspell cool there's no water
coming from Barbie's shower head or
liquid in the milk carton that she
drinks from which would be the case in a
girl's tea party but also it's kind of
just creepy to see Margot Robbie act
this out like scorsese's shot and
Shutter Island when that woman takes a
sip from the water glass but there's
nothing in her hand gonna awake and
Margot Robbie pull off something
impressive here though Barbie catches
this plastic waffle and plastic butter
on her plate I thought the waffle might
have been be effects but as you watch it
throughout the scene it stays on the
plate and it looks real I think she
caught it practically like Toby with his
lunch tray in Spider-Man using magnets
and stuff also in the background
Barbie's neighbor's waffle pops out at
the exact same time hers does Barbie
floats down from a roof no stairs
necessary because kids would just kind
of lift the doll off the roof and her
dress Billows up an homage to Marilyn
Monroe in a Seven Year Itch Margot
Robbie also played Omaha Monroe and
birds of prey when Harley Quinn
reenacted Diamonds Are a Girl's Best
Friend from Gentlemen Prefer blunts just
pointed out how behind her inside her
house is hanging a Jackie O style
business suit which could make this kind
of like that knowingly problematic
madman bit where they said that all
women are either a Jackie or Marilyn now
Barbie obviously shattered that BS
dichotomy throughout the 60s and 70s but
it's just interesting how both this
movie and madman brought it up to show
the evolution of American Marketing
Emerald fennel plays Midge now Midge was
introduced back in the 60s as Barbie's
best friend but her pregnancy here is a
nod to the Happy Family Doll from 2003 a
pregnant doll that was quickly pulled
from the shelves she's nearby life-sized
purple Chelsea doll tree house we made
the others in Barbie's World Issa Ray
plays President Barbie Nobel prizes are
handed off to Alexander ship who plays
writer Barbie and the Mackey who plays
physicist Barbie Sharon Rooney plays
lawyer Barbie arguing before an
all-female Barbie Supreme Court
including judge Barbie played by Anna
Cruz Kane Dua Lipa cameos this movie as
the mermaid Barbies Ritu Arya plays the
reporter Barbie Nicola Coughlin plays
Diplomat Barbie Hari nav plays Dr Barbie
who drives an open up ambulance which is
pretty much a recreation of the Barbie
Care Clinic vehicle Barbie drives around
through Barbie land and we see b-a-x
instead of LAX a pink Statue of Liberty
a pink Capital Dome a pink house to the
White House and a Barbie Mount Rushmore
in the cinema she drives past plays The
Wizard of Oz where there are various
posters of the characters from the movie
notice how Barbie wears pink gingham
like Dorothy Gales blue gingham and the
road out of Barbie land is a pink brick
road as this plot follows the story of
The Wizard of Oz Barbie is really the
dreamer Dorothy who Journeys into a
magical world I guess that would make
Ken her Toto or maybe the Tin man who
just wants a heart either way I think
the wizard is Will Ferrell's Mattel CEO
I guess that would make Ruth Handler
Glinda the Good Witch Barbie also drives
past the candy store I.E playoff you
know Candy but candy spelled I.E is also
one of the Puffs from the Barbie
collection to the beach there are nods
to Barbie toys The Umbrellas resemble
the ones from Barbie's Glam pool you can
see an ice cream shop that really does
look like the Barbie soda shop from back
in the day mixed with the Barbie's ice
cream truck set the sand on the beach is
pink plastic the water of course plastic
too the flags do not move in the wind
Barbie does not leave Footprints and
remember Barbie earlier walked across
the plastic water of her pool so yes
she's
the beach attire on Barbie has a style
of the Sun and Beach Barbie from the
late 90s that Barbie Sports a seashell
necklace like the one she is wearing
here and we meet the men Ryan Gosling
plays Ken who's obsessed with Barbie and
only has a good day which looks at him
Kingsley benedir plays kid number one
who's Ken's best friend simulu plays Ken
number two Ken's rival Scott Evans and
Gucci guatua play two more Kens John
Cena later cameos as a Ken made and
Michael Sarah plays Allen Allen was
introduced in 1964 as Ken's buddy
wearing these exact clothes he
originally went on to Merry Midge but
that's not the case with the Allen in
this movie the idea of Alan was that he
was supposed to be Ken size and then the
two could share clothes so he's just
deeply worried when Ken tries to Surf we
get a dolly zoom on Alan just like
Steven Spielberg's Dolly zoom on Brody
when he was on the beach and jaws and
yes the cans have some unfortunate
phrasing with the word Beach anyone who
wants to beat him off has to beat me off
first I will beat both of you off at the
same time but you don't even know how to
beat yourself off
look at the beach both of us
I love how wind suken threatens to Beach
them both off we got back to Alan
staring intently I mean now as Ken gets
checked up and Dr Barbie's fold-out
ambulance care vehicle he addresses the
common misconception that Ken is a
lifeguard and that really his profession
is just Beach Barbie holds a big house
party with a rotating circular Dance
Floor since time for all of them is a
flat circle where the day's reset at the
top like a narrative Loop in Westworld
what skips that Loop though is Barbie in
the middle of this dance floor asking do
you guys ever think about dying
and literally the whole structure of the
movie now skips like a scratch in the
record during this party Allen dances on
his own Rhythm showing that he's not
exactly a Ken like the others Greta
gurway conceived this movie to be like
the classic Technicolor musicals like
the red shoes and The Umbrellas of
cherborg saying they all have a high
level of what we came to call authentic
artificiality you have a Painted Sky and
a Sound Stage which is illusion but it's
also really there the painted backdrop
is really there the tangibility of the
artifice is something that we kept going
back to now notice how all the kids wear
these white jumpsuits with K's all of
them in a line and I don't know about
you but whatever you got three K's in a
row and white clothes that's Oahu
because yeah these cans when they get
together and connect they're pretty
problematic I also noticed this might
just be me watching Love is Blind with
my wife they're all drinking out of
these gold wine cups which when my wife
and I watch Love and blind I'm like why
are they always drinking at these gold
cups and she had to explain to me that
the editors and producers of the show
did this so that they could easily
reassemble scenes as the booze line went
up and down in the glasses because the
beautiful fools of the show are forced
to drink and fight and drink some more
just for our merry mint so Barbie turns
down Ken from staying the night so that
they can a girl's night and they say
president Barbie's here president
Barbie's like I am you're welcome which
I don't know kind of feels like a nod to
my favorite Beyonce clip you are Beyonce
and his Ken walks off he continues doing
that shimmy thrust that he did with
Barbie's hips earlier but after her
existential dread the next morning
Barbie sleeps in and her morning routine
is just off she reacts to cold invisible
water her waffle is burnt and then she
falls with a thud off the roof like a
doll being dropped by a girl who has
lost interest in her and notice how
lizzo's lyrics here are now pee panic I
I'm scared and nauseous okay death
whereas before when Barbie stepped out
of her heels her feet would stay pointed
now her feet go flat Dr Barbie screams
[Applause]
this idea of going from pointed feet to
flat feet I just think is important
symbolism for the character as even
though flat feet would be more
comfortable a more grounded pose it's
just still awkward and disoriented for
this Barbie who has had to be an object
and so she must visit weird Barbie Kate
McKinnon the Barbie who's been played
with too much so that her face has been
colored on and her hair has been cut
awkwardly and she's always doing the
splits actually in the quick flashback
we see the girl who did this tour and in
this play for it you can see the name on
the pole g-l-o-r-i-a Gloria this is
Gloria this is America Ferreira as a
child the same girl who played with
stereotypical Barbie as an adult is the
one who made weird Barbie weird she is
really the focal dreamer of the story
that the Barbies of Barbie land live
inside the imagination of also weird
Barbie has a potty puff that drops
little plastic poops like the one from
the Barbie walk and potty pup set so
weird Barbie whose name reminds me of
the weird sisters the prophetic witches
of Macbeth explains the logic of this
world or rather doesn't explain the
logic of it she says there's no actual
portal or Rift there's just this tedious
path that Vehicles one would have to
take to the real world to find a girl
playing with her and fix what's wrong
with her that is Barbie's quest in this
movie and yes weird Barbie pays homage
to The Matrix with a red pill versus
blue pill Choice the heels or the
Birkenstock return to the simulation or
go to the real world Barbie chooses blue
pill option right away without
hesitation and notice how behind Barbie
is weird Barbie's World Map which is
intentionally wrong and inaccurate you
can see on the map Australia is written
upside down as it's in the southern
hemisphere England has a crown on it but
this map got the film into some trouble
movies banned in Vietnam and they got
requests to blur this map from the
Philippines as this map allegedly shows
the nine dash line which is a maritime
border running through the South China
Sea and is currently a disputed region
claimed by China a claim not recognized
by Vietnam the Philippines and other
countries in response Warner Brothers
said that this image was meant to be a
childlike crayon drawing weird Barbie
even calls us out by saying she's headed
to the state of Los Angeles in the
country of California and yeah la does
have its own weirdly complex City versus
County jurisdictional system and
California is large enough to have on
its own the fifth largest economy in the
world the other Barbies throw a goodbye
party with a really long Banner that
reads Bon Voyage to reality and good
luck with storing the membrane between
our world and there so you don't get
cellulite as Barbie departs Barbie land
in the desert is a Warner Brothers water
tower you know like the one that the
Animaniacs live in now as you drive she
sings the Indigo Girls Closer To Fine
which really becomes the Barbie's
therapeutic Sing-along song in this
movie meanwhile the kids sing Matchbox
twenties push I wanna push you around
well I will which a song that came under
criticism in the late 90s when finished
groups claimed it was about abusing
women Rob Thomas claimed the man in the
song is the one being abused but um yeah
the lyrics of this song are not great
like in another Will Ferrell movie Elf
we get a storybook travel montage by car
by boat on a space rocket on a tandem
bike through Holland can't be in
snowmobile and eventually rollerblade in
Venice Beach notice how in space Barbie
wears the space suit with brown gloves
and boots from the 60s my favorite
career Barbie sets now later when Kim
returns to Barbie land notice how even
alone through each of these travel steps
he still takes the same position he did
before like he hangs off the back of the
rocket even though no one's sitting on
the front of it and he sits in the back
of the boat still afraid of the seagulls
and yes the seagulls the balloons of
planets in this travel Montage they're
all held up by strings now rollerblading
the real world the first thing they
notice is how much the people in Venice
sexualize them right away both of them
Barbie gets assaulted and both Barbie
and Ken get arrested Ken's placard reads
and Ken because his Arc in this movie is
that he's always been and Ken he's
always been a side piece he's going from
and Ken to just Ken they get new cowboy
and cowgirl outfits and they get
arrested again and they had to century
city which can later idolize is this
some kind of enlightened Utopia everyone
in L.A knows that Century City is really
just a steel and concrete dead zone for
corporate decision making best known as
the skyscraper that serves the sakitomi
plaza and die hard yeah man as Ken takes
in the Bros of the gym notice how the
music resamples the theme from 2001 A
Space Odyssey making this really the
dawn of Ken meanwhile Barbie sits on a
park bench inside an older woman this is
actually a cameo by Anne Roth an academy
award-winning costume designer who
worked with Greta Gerwig in the film
White Noise we head to the Mattel HQ
where right away we see America Ferreira
as Gloria drawing some really impressive
Barbie concept art we meet Will Ferrell
as a Mattel CEO reminding us of how he
played the Evil CEO aka the dad in The
Lego Movie outside the window the
skyscraper you can see a Warner Brothers
Discovery building boo but beyond that
you can see snow-capped mountains now
I'm sorry I have to point this out I
lived in La for 12 years and while the
LA Basin is surrounded by the North and
the east by mountain ranges and that on
a very clear day in winter and spring
you might be able to see some snow caps
you can almost never see these mountains
this clearly from Century City from
downtown LA or from Mattel's actual
corporate headquarters in El Segundo so
really the most confusing part of this
movie to me is why Will Ferrell and his
goons act so cartoonish like they're in
Barbie land 2 when Gloria and her
daughter act grounded and normal I guess
it's just that the Mattel building is
presented as a kind of magical Zone
where Barbie briefly meets Ruth Handler
inventor of Barbie a ghost on the 17th
floor of this building played by Raya
Perman wearing a Handler's signature
blue top and white necklace that she's
often photographed wearing when she
returns later she makes a reference to
her income tax evasion crimes which
really were issues that her family went
through Barbie returns to Barbie land
with Gloria and Sasha and sees that Ken
has transformed it into Kingdom horses
are now on Mount Rushmore all the
Barbies are serving Ken's Alan joins
forces with the non-brainwashed Barbies
and he drops at the members of insync
were apparently all Allen's which I
guess is kind of a compliment based off
this movie they regroup at weird
Barbie's house where we see the sugar
daddy kin and the magic kid there
actually was a really weird Palm Beach
Sugar Daddy can with a tiny dog from
2009 meanwhile in 1993 there was an
earring magic Ken who's recognized as
something of a gay symbol based off of
which ear the earring was in and a
necklace that people joked looked like a
crane we also made a Barbie with a TV be
in her back and a skipper who's breast
inflate and there really was a pretty
messed up Growing Up Skipper doll from
1975 that did this yikes so Gloria gets
a super cathartic monologue in the scene
discussing the impossible standards of
being a woman and you can tell greater
Gerwig was just unleashing in the scene
and I really love it because each
impossible standard that she mentions
you can imagine forming one of the
Barbies that we've met in Barbie land in
this movie weird Barbie also drops a
great line in the scene quote either
you're brainwashed or you're ugly there
is no in between and I'm just singling
out this line because like Luther and
rael's monologue in Andor or the line
what is grief if not love persevering in
one division it's just a kind of great
quotable writing you know we'll get
quoted in the future and no AI cannot
write this for that matter digital scans
cannot replicate what Margot Robbie Ryan
Gosling and the entire cast did in this
movie also we cannot forget my favorite
line of this movie when Barbie sobs I'm
not stereotypically Barbie pretty and
Hell Amir without missing a beat drops
in to say no to filmmaker Margot Robbie
is the wrong person to cast if you want
to make this point and it's the kind of
joke they'd hear Ron Howard's narrator
make in the rest of development it's one
of my favorite examples of what's called
hanging the lantern in screenwriting
it's a term for when you acknowledge the
Ridiculousness of the moment or the
quick joke and get back out and really
it's just the timing of it that is
perfect so the Barbie's plot to awaken
each Barbie from the brainwashing by
distracting each kid with a vapid
girlfriend tropes that guys like like
watching The Godfather and talking all
the way through it or taking off classes
and be the first to discover her inner
beauty this operation successfully turns
the kins against each other and they go
to war in a D-Day style Beach Invasion
meanwhile the Barbies vote unfix of the
Constitution and we end with Barbie
rejoining Ruth Handler in a void a scene
similar to Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz
asking what's for her and Glinda the
Good Witch takes her aside to cast a
spell over her Ruth explains people make
up things like patriarchy and Barbie
just to deal with how uncomfortable it
is and Barbie says I want to be a part
of the people that make meaning not the
thing that's made I want to do the
imagining I don't want to be the idea
and you just have to imagine Greta
Gerwig here an award-winning actress and
writer wanted to be more than just an
object on screen but a writer director
behind the scenes wanting to be in the
position of power to imagine the ways to
express these complex thoughts and Ruth
tells her that her name Barbie comes
from her daughter Barbara and says we
mothers stand still so that our
daughters can look back to see how far
they've come now look I'm a guy I'm
somewhere between a Ken and an allen but
when I hear this line I imagine my wife
with her mom I imagine my mom with my
sisters I imagine every woman I know in
my life who's a mother or daughter I
think I figured it out Glinda the Good
Witch is the mom that Dorothy thought
she needed pointing her back home to the
aunt M that she always had and please
for the love of God watch Diana Ross
singing home in The Wiz because there
truly is no place like it for Barbie she
literally is the dream of the girl who
dreamed her up her spiritual mother is
Gloria and that's the home she returns
to in this movie flat-footed and
Birkenstocks getting her first
gynecologist appointment and we'll leave
it there thanks for watching new
rockstars and I'll see you next time bye
thank you
[Music]